اعلن رئيس الوزراء اسلوبكيه ادوارد ان
بلاده هو فقط على ارسال ثلاثه عشره مقاتله
من طراز ميج 29 الى اوكرانيا ووضع رئيس
الوزراء السلوكي هذا الامر في ايطالي
ايفاء الوعود التي قطعت ها بلاده للرئيس
الاوكراني بوليودمير زينسكي بتزويدك
باسلحه اضافيه بما فيها الطائرات الحربيه
يذكر ان الحكومه البولنديه اعلنت امس عن
نياتها في تسريع عمليه تسليم اوكرانيا
اربع طائرات حربيه على الاقل من الطراز
نفسه
اوكرانيا مقاتله 29 خطوه تعد الاولى من
نوعها بين دول النيتو وتريد بولندا نقل
هذه المقاتلات الى اوكرانيا في اطار
التحالف اكبر من الدول لدى بولندا
وسلوفاكيا اسطول من طائره ميغ سوفيتيه
يجري اعداد وصيانه الطائرات حاليا
لارسالها الى اوكرانيا واوضحت بولندا ان
مقاتله 29 هي طائرات يمكن للطيارين
الاوكرانيين استخدامها اليوم من دون تدريب
اضافي وقد نجحت اوكرانيا في تعديل مقاتله
ميكس 29 لتحمل صواريخ هرم الامريكيه
المضاده للرادار واستخدمتها ضد المواقع
الروسيه في اوكرانيا وكانت السويد قد
اعلنت امس الخميس عن صفقه لبيع نظامها من
سلاح المدفعيه ذاتيه الحركه ارتشر الى
بريطانيا ما يتيح لندن منحى نظام الم هي
الاقدم اي اس 90 الذي تملكه الى اوكرانيا
وقالت الحكومه السويديه في بيان ان
بريطانيا ستشتري 14 وحده من مدفعيه ارتشر
وذكرت بريطانيا ان وحدات الاربعه عشر التي
ستشتريها من السويد ستكون بديلا مؤقتا
لاثنتين واحده من نظام اي اس 90 ستمنح
للقوات المسلحه الاوكرانيه